hi in this video i'm going to share a
cool mnemonics to remember the
structures and the names of the dna
viruses so this mnemonics states that
our dna viruses are happy viruses
so now we would spell happy in a
different way we would write h h a
triple p y for happy and let's see what
happy means happy means
harpis hepadna adreno
papova parvo and pox
now here comes the
structure
so let's see which viruses are enveloped
and which are not enveloped that means
naked so three viruses are naked
that means they don't have envelope so
these are papova adeno and powerful and
the mnemonics is
a pap smear test a woman must be naked
for a pap smear exam that is why we
should remember it as pap papova i
didn't know and powerful and then three
are enveloped herpes box and hepatna we
could remember it like
high profile hat so all of these three
viruses were high profile hat and
for pox
the symmetry the symmetry is complex for
other all viruses the symmetry of the
capsid is icosahedral so that was all
about the dna viruses its structure and
its
names so if you like my video please
give it a quick thumbs up
and please share and leave your comments
below thank you